[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Lindsay's
with us in Waco Texas hi Lindsay how are
you I'm good how are y'all better than
we deserve what's
up so I'm in a little bit of a pickle my
husband wants to buy a brand new stop
outside so let me give you some
context yesterday we closed in our house
um we will take home a little over
33,000 on it you sold your house paid
for you sold your house okay you got 33
$30,000 in your pocket okay yes our
current house that we're living in our
new house is paid for cool um we're I
convinced him to take 29,000 of that and
pay off his
truck and now he wants to go buy a brand
new stop outside and I'm like but we
have other things I need to pay for and
I keep telling him no and he keeps
saying I we we have money now I'm like
we don't we don't have money well not if
he spends it on a side by side you don't
have any money no I don't have money let
me stop a second you don't have the
money to buy side by side right no okay
so he's talking about talking to go buy
one this is the same man that yesterday
paid off his truck and now he wants to
go back in debt so he's not really on
the get out of debt plan he's just kind
of going along when you tell him to do
something until he doesn't want to do it
yeah yeah so this is not a money problem
this is a husband
problem I agree okay so how old are you
two uh we just both turned 37 on Sunday
and Tuesday this week what's he do for a
living He is um a heavy equipment
mechanic by trade but he just got into
inside sales which promoted him like
upgrad him on his hourly wages yeah
but's he's a he's a mechanic by trade
what do you do
I'm an occupational therapist assistant
we I gross um and what other debts do
you have now that his truck is paid
off I have we have a camper that we
bought and we do use it we use it like
almost I don't care what other the debts
have you got I know you don't care um I
have a camper and student loans that's
it how much is a camper
debt UH 60
$60,000 yes
that that wasn't of my choice either yes
it was you're a grownup and you live
there and you signed the papers I didn't
sign anything how is he buying this like
when this H when this goes down what
takes place he goes over to the dealer
on his own signs for it and says honey
look I bought us a camper is that what
happens what he does is he says I'm
gonna go buy this I'm like no I don't
have the I I I can't I'm paying off
other stuff we're paying off other stuff
we we can't and he goes and and he does
it he goes and does it
anyway he does okay we have a side by
side it's paid for I I said you you
already have a paid four side by side
what is it worth yes
um
22 and it's used yeah okay and what how
much student loan debt do you have H 55
oh okay so you
have $15,000 in debt and I paid 4 house
and your household income is what
100 it's aund and this year I think
it'll be 162 oh okay that's excellent
all right well I mean you guys need to
sit down and not have a sideb side
discussion you need to sit down and have
a marriage
discussion yes sir and say I love you
and I'm tired of being your mother I
don't want to be married to a little boy
who has to ask his mommy to make
decisions I want a man who stands beside
me and looks into the future and says
how can we Prosper as a family and puts
his own little selfish desires to the
side of the good of the family I need a
man would you please find me
one and I'm going to make a call out
here here's just this is what I think I
think that you guys started making a
little bit of money and you started
doing may this is my guess a little
better than some of the the way maybe
you're you grew up and I think he thinks
you guys are rich and I think he thinks
this is what people with money
do am I right and especially yesterday
after we closed on the house he's like
we don't have a health family anymore I
said no cuz that's going to go to
something else yeah now you make1
160,000 and you got a stupid butt
$60,000 camper and $55,000 worth a
student loan debt to clean up and then
you can go build some wealth and then
you can side by side if you want to
upgrade your side by side with cash when
you're not in debt anymore but that's
what men do what grownup women do not
little boys and little girls who buy
toys that they can't afford and this is
the discussion the two of you need to
have uh hey I've got a side by side
nothing wrong with them but quit buying
crap you can't afford create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life